le temps est bien le soleil brillait un
peu partout aujourd'hui les plages
aujourd'hui était noire de monde bien
sûr et quand le soleil brille les corps
se dénudent c'est en tout cas la mode
l'année dernière c'était la mode l'année
dernière mais il semble que les modes
changent assez vite d'une année à
l'autre la tendance en effet cette année
en début d'été c'est le retour un peu
plus de tissu sur la peau c'est en tout
cas ce qu'a constaté jean jacques dufour
sur la côte d'azur le string cette
ficelle qui ne protégeait pas des rayons
du soleil n'est plus à la mode cette
année sur les plages les femmes du
torride et enroule à 12 brésil bien un
art où l'ado ce n'est pas un prêtre venu
c'est un maillot que l'on roule pour
mieux bronzer et une pièce façon film
hollywoodien des années 50 sont
également de retour sur nos plages jany
trauque la terre est ce que j'aime bien
mais mes yeux doux ce qui tendrait à
prouver que quand on aime on ne compte
pas
il vous avez h localement sont cette
année alors celui là qui est un petit
peu excentrique de pièces mais original
et de maillots une pièce
lorsque les maillots une pièce on est
amis on est fait de façon à ce qu'on
puisse les rouler les mettre en pièces
donc vous pouvez bronzé et vous leur
montée pour aller à l'eau par exemple et
pour moi qui suis pas très grande g
prend très vexé échancré et ça ça me
grandit et vous les choisissez en
fonction de voir
illzach où tu combien maillot brésilien
en tout 400
quelles sont bons quel sens va prendre
quoi
à propos vous savez combien il s'est
vendu très petits morceaux de tissu 100
millions l'année dernière en europe 18
millions en france le maillot de bain
c'est donc une industrie mais c'est
aussi une façon d'exprimer sa
personnalité ou de soigner son look
donc les mâles qui désirent être
peaufiné leur image de marque doivent
savoir qu'on porte désormais des
caleçons des bermudas pas trop long dans
ce genre là regardez le maillot deux
heures ouais ça vous d'importance qui
finit un petit peu dépassé
à y aller y aller comme moi cheek ya les
autres les petits maillots horrible pas
beau mais si certains choisissent eux
mêmes d'autres subissent l'influencé de
leurs compagnes et ne savent plus à quel
saint se vouer
j'allais pas de ma femme on est
d'éloigner le cours de promenade un
simple elle que choisir pour quelques
esthètes les maillots doivent ressembler
à des paquets de gâteaux l'emballage
car devinez lisa très positif de la tête
et quand vous regardez le maillot de
bain des eaux les hommes ou des femmes
qu'est ce que vous regardez à 95% et
trouve pas beau quoi qu'il en soit dans
la rubrique moi tarzan toi jane
il reste que sur les plages qu'elle
saisirait dit qu'ils semblent bien
décidés à n'en faire qu'à leur tête